hey gang you sewed upon the new rock
stars Channel welcome today let's talk
about the flash episode 402 mixed
signals specifically let's unpack those
hidden references Easter eggs impossible
hints as to where this season of the
solo Scarlet speedster adventures could
go use your spoiler warning for the
flash DC TV show comics and beyond like
last week's episode for the season 4
premiere let's do this in the top 10
style cut people love it I love it we
all love it especially the editors cuz
anyone did this in chronological order a
day now just for funsies let's do a
quick recap of the episode BAM Barry is
back and he's ready to be the protector
of central city once again but not so
fast mister you're stepping on some toes
specifically your fiance's area and iris
go into a little relationship counseling
while the rest of the team takes on
Kilgore kil G percentage sign re it's
great name that dumb at all I don't
worry just a square pupil villain whose
DNA is not made up of ones and zeros
allowing him to control technology with
his brain well Kilgore stomps around
killing tech billionaires iris and Barry
begin to resolve their issue Cisco and
celebrate other Earth's holidays
and Wally and Joe do some father-son
staking out classic at the end of the
episode we're left with hints that maybe
the thinker and mechanic have been
creating their very own metas who could
they be we don't know excited to find
out in future episodes though but let's
begin our top 10 list starting with
number 10 Kilgore himself Kilgore played
by Dominic Burgess loved him in It's
Always Sunny and the good place has been
in comics for a few years now originally
appearing in flash volume 2 issue 3 in
1987 and has had his history simplified
just a little bit now he's just a meta
not a living computer virus of alien
origin was recently killed were actually
showed up in the cyborg rebirth number
one special which is pretty cool but now
he has this complex mechanical body
which i think is a little bit cooler
than a computer virus but it's just me I
love this character design or mainly his
you know purple square pupils that I
feel are definitely nods to different
nerdy properties the first being the
square pupils with the technological
background seem to be a reference
offender the humanoid robot from
Futurama pretty cool because we're
pupils and that vindictive personality
seems to line up pretty well we went on
to number 9 after that grisly
introduction of Kilgore we see barek
danced around his underoos and that
button up now this isn't exactly the
number 9 Easter egg not
long shot but it is worth mentioning
this outfit in lip-syncing into the
spatula is a spot-on not to the very
popular movie risky business I'm sure
most of you are probably familiar with
this scene because every show and movie
ever has copied it but for those of you
who missed it the main character played
by Tom Cruise dances to old time rock
and roll as a way to express his
newfound freedom like Barry there he's
just dancing away all the drama from the
past few seasons you know I mean now
here's the real easter egg in this scene
where Barry is speed binging all the
shows he's missed since he was gone
notice Oh Jon Snow died oh he's alive
first fans would probably say hey
Honeybear he hasn't been watching Game
of Thrones for a couple years since Jon
Snow's death and then undeath happened
back in 2015 and then 2016 or the
timeline of this show is just all over
the place maybe flashpoint a few more
repercussions than just murdering your
best friend's brother and making an evil
speedster clone of yourself and probably
read too far into it but while this
little mentioned the kingdom north is
light-hearted and fun this is also feel
like a slight dig at the CW DC shows
maybe making fun of themselves a little
bit might be the characters on these
shows don't always you know stay dead
just like Sarah Lance a.k Black Canary
number 188 canary ok white canary now
she died in season 1 but then returned
because he wasn't actually dead and then
BAM she was filled with arrows and then
thrown off a roof and then BAM they
threw her into a Lazarus Pit hey maybe
this is the dig at comic books in
general since everybody knows and comic
well characters never stay dead Superman
dead came back Green Lantern dad and
then he came back Batman barely dead
maybe dead for a few issues then he came
back they actually I mean done a few
times but then big one flash he was dead
for decades then came back boy this
could just be a dig at the flash show in
particular Barry couldn't even pretend
to be dead for one whole episode this
season can't stay mad though I love this
crap next up number 8 the new suit Cisco
officially unveils new suit they's
manufactured for Barry and all the
upgrades notice how Barry says that he's
already familiar with this suit though
sure could be a callback to the premiere
of this season he just slips into it to
save iris from the samurai but he's also
possibly probably throwing back to the
previous season season 3 anybody
remember in episode 319 the once and
future flash when buried ranted the
future to get the scoop on savat are
from emo Barry when pass Barry tried to
take on the Rogues of the future emo
Barry to read this email clothes and
Don's the new and improved Flash uniform
a cape
at Cisco has just made me take away this
line of knowing the suit could be
interpreted as shut up Cisco I saw the
suit months ago ketchup I personally
prefer this suit to the one we've had
over the past couple seasons mainly
because it's actually looking more like
the Flash's costume in the comics others
the improved belt looks like a lightning
bolt no brighter colors all around the
gold gauntlets on the wrists and by the
feet yet the gold lightning bolts on the
side of the head that look awesome
overall I'm a fan Cisco even installed a
heads-up display form which makes me
excited for two reasons one this looks
more like the eye guards we see on Wally
West's flash costume a little bit of
white that covers them on a suit also a
little bit kind of like impulses I wear
since it's the same color I'm a big fan
because I wouldn't a speedster wear I
wear four how fast they're running I
don't know there's probably coming quick
reason why he doesn't and to with the AI
in the suit with Cisco's voice we're
another step closer to having Gideon
installed in his suit remember Gideon
she was the AI professor Wells was using
to plot his return to the future in
season one of the flash and is now the
current AI on the Waverider for legends
of tomorrow well it was revealed back in
season one that Barry created this AI
but in the future which is pretty neat
now one minor flaw notice the options
listed on the heads-up display the small
selection of the numerous abilities this
suit is supposed to have most of you
clever boys and girls Republican to
notice right away that those are the
options listed later in the show
deadlock pulse cannons babble protocol
from comics maybe something to do with
them certain Dark Knight I'm getting
ahead of myself don't worry I'll get
there soon number seven notice the
digital display in Tim Kwan's logo
removed Tesla Model X Tim here is
listening to generic pop music but the
station keeps changing signaling
nefarious interference the zation that
overpowers the eric pop music is titled
heavy metal hmm I think this is a nod to
Kilgore's DC rebirth upgrade you know
the one from the cyborg comic no longer
he's just some random bit of code that
infects technology and sometimes people
no no now he's got his very own metallic
body sure his new body is a bit of a
mess if you like these pictures but it
is impressive in strength size and
durability
aka it's heavy this is a stretch but I'm
counting at number six after the mess up
when Barry has to disassemble a car in
just a few seconds which was awesome by
the way
iris asks Barry if they can attend
couples therapy which I think in a very
mature decision for the show to do I
actually love that scene not only did it
lead to
genuinely funny moments but it also
addresses a big top point mayor he left
for six months this actually affects be
proud of the baton notice the headline
on the newspaper that Barry shows iris
what row Oliver Queen secret identity is
outed to the public love this makes
sense in the world that they live and of
course this would be in the top headline
of every newspaper in the country but
also if X is like a little advertisement
for the other CW shows on the network
it's basically saying hey you live in
the flash right now but look how crazy
things are over on arrow whoa check it
on Thursdays also if you happen to catch
the newest arrow episode or you are
following air on Twitter and you saw a
little snippet they released there's a
pretty big shout-out in this episode
towards the Dark Knight's alter ego they
could have put Bruce Wayne's head on
that body as Bruce Wayne left Gotham to
hang out in Star City recently that's
right Bruce Wayne hey that's so cool
which does circle back to the babble
protocol but again we're almost there
also comic book fans Barry's slightly
aversion to a therapy feel similar to
the scene in the more recent new 52 run
of Barry Allen as a flash in issue 30 to
be specific after the major comic book
event forever evil when evil
doppelgangers of the Justice League from
Earth 3 took over the years area was
forced to see a therapist because you
should it's very traumatic
however he couldn't sit still for too
long and sneaks off when the therapist
isn't looking to help repair Central
City kinda wish we got a little bit of
that in today's episode but I'm still
happy with what we got
moving on to number 5 still sticking
with a therapy scene pay attention to
this line from Barry I think that hardly
rises to the level of a crisis oh boy so
much excites me about this the end of
the show we've had our fair share of
crises from the black hole over Central
City and season 1 to the multiverse bomb
at the end of season 2 to the speed or
storm in almost annihilated the city and
the universe I'm guessing at the end of
last season we've even been dreading
that impending crisis that's been
prophesized since episode 1 with the
newspaper headline from 2024
however crisis has been an important
title for the flash events in comics
from the big one crisis on Infinite
Earths where Barry Allen literally
sacrifices himself to save the
multiverse to Final Crisis when that's
all reverse and Barry Allen is brought
back to life because it's this awesome
moment where Barry and while they team
up here
of the day see that Jon Snow jab comes
out full circle but I really think this
has to do with the big crossover coming
later this year anybody you remember in
the title of that crossover that's right
crisis sun-earth X earth 10 that's not
the fault it's just crisis on earth
Roman numeral probably this is a massive
crossover event between flash arrow
Supergirl legends of tomorrow and the
brand-new Rey animated show coming to CW
see our heroes will be facing off with
evil Nazi versions of themselves cool
how we're excited to you guys I'm gonna
pee myself I'm so excited up next number
four scooting forward to our final
showdown with Kilgore in the factory I
believe or maybe a car shop really not
specific but who cares because I want to
talk about the hidden goodies in Berry's
suit now let's focus on pulse cannons
for practical purposes I get why this
weapon was added to the suit the only
projectile Barry has right now is the
lightning bolt but it kind of takes him
a long time for him which means that's
crazy it takes him a long time to build
that up and then throw it this way he
just points the shoes which is a bummer
for Wally however do these pulses look
familiar
anybody most fans will probably shout
Iron Man because of the sound in the
composition and the color of the beams
and I get it but I think Cisco got
another inspiration for these babies you
guys think of anybody else who uses
beams like this I'm thinking he hit up
his friend over on the Waverider
Ray Palmer ray aka the atom has an
exosuit allows them to shrink but it
also fires energy blast and they do look
and sound different from Barry's but hey
just kind of make sense why they would
be different you know what I mean Ray's
blasters are blue because his costume
was blue berries are yellow cause it's
got yellow lightning and his costume is
yellow dust all about branding number
three it's time to talk about that
Batman reference I've been mentioning uh
all episode get ready kids because it's
terrifying and badass notice the babble
protocol that Cisco installs in the suit
at first I thought it was going to be
you know able a scramble Barry's speech
thinking of the literal meaning of
babble you know the Tower of Babel story
which I'll get to in a second but it
actually is a callback to the extremely
popular
Justice League comic event JLA Tower of
Babel back in the early 2000s was an
event where Rachel Ghul steals Batman's
contingency plans for the Justice League
and turns it against them why does Bruce
have these plans because he's preparing
like men he's Batman he's crazy
basically they're his plans to
take down the league one by one in case
they become a threat reason why it's
called tower Babel is actually called
back to the biblical story of the tower
that humans tried to build up to heaven
but God strikes the citizens with
different languages so they could no
longer work together the connection to
this comic being that these contingency
plans hair apart the league from the
inside the difference here that instead
of an exploding suit Batman in the
comics created a special bullet that
when it hits Wally West's flash it
causes them to have seizures at
Lightspeed
that's a goddang nightmare Batman's kind
of a jerk anyway on to number two after
Kilgore is dropped off at iron Heights
we meet the new warden of the prison mr.
wolf or warden wolf at the end of the
scene we see wolf staring in on Kilgore
at his cell and he's looking menacing
maybe honestly this thing was kind of
strange but this was a big red flag for
me if you remember from my previous
video I mentioned that this season seems
to be modeled after the very popular
Wally West story written by Geoff Johns
that stars the thinker and Amma net both
characters introduced last week now this
week I'm basically a hundred percent
sure now that this season is based on
that story or at least the show's going
to try to attempt to adapt that story
because warden wolf was created during
that series little background on him
he's a tough warden of iron Heights that
is revealed to have special abilities
and he was abusing meta prisoners he's
not a great guy basically he can
psychically inflict pain on individuals
by causing muscle spasms it's terrifying
when you think about you know that
combined with Wolf's temper problems
what does word wolf have planned for
Kilgore in this series uh really sure
yet but I'm definitely interested to
find out he's actually one of my
favorite characters in flash comics
night of all time but lastly number one
the pig tease for the rest of the season
happen in the final shot of this episode
let's take a look at this shot I'm
counting 12 slots 11 of missing Mehta's
that apparently created by the thinker
and the mechanic Co gore being the 12th
but who could the other 11 be it's a bit
difficult to tell right now since this
isn't quite a plot point from the comics
as far as I can tell based on my
research but it is definitely
interesting based on the news we've
received from the studios here my guests
are a few of them first off a minute I
think she's gonna be one of the other
big beds of this season and she was
mentioned in the premiere her name is
also blacksmith a character who can
emerge
her flesh with metal which does kind of
sound like an ability that someone like
the mechanic could create sounds about
right
I'm not sure my guess I'm gonna gain her
powers from the thinker and then
rebelled she ran off and created this
underground network of metas that she's
now calling the network from the comics
and now she's making her own team of
rogues I'm excited to see her played by
Katee Sackhoff and see what they do with
her character but the big character that
I think might be tied to this will be
Ralph Dib nee aka the elongated man I'm
very excited for this character now in
the comics the elongated man is another
elastic hero but he's also mixed with
the intelligence of Batman so he's
pretty cool he's one of the best
detectives on the planet elongated man
made his debut in the flash comics as a
kind of a mess but he grew into a fairly
popular hero now in the show he'll be
played by Hartley Sawyer which I'm
excited to see how he plays him and will
be somewhat of an old rival from Barry's
past or if I were to guess how this
could play out Ralph may hide where he
got his abilities from and it will be
this big reveal slash betrayal when we
find out that he's in cahoots with a
thinker but at the last second I'll have
a change of heart or mind and he'll help
team flash save the day or the writers
will kind of burn through that plot like
they normally do then one or maybe two
episodes could be totally wrong as for
other characters who do you think will
make an appearance maybe a new version
of old characters I wouldn't mind seeing
a more comic accurate version of girder
that's you know closer to like that a
really messed up look or maybe the
folding man you can fold his body into
the second and then to the fourth
dimension can teleport with it let me
know what you think in the comments down
below now really quick guys honorable
mentions I like mentioning them when I
do these videos first up we see the STAR
Labs exterior a few times in this show
and both times they looks different one
shot we see it looks like it's from
season 1 through 3 where it's burned and
torn apart on the outside while other
shots would like they're from the
premiere when they're you know starting
to be repaired let's be real Barry
Wally Jesse J just sit down for one
afternoon and just knock it out repair
the whole dang thing I want to mention
the joke about all the people who have
died on these shows we got Barry's mom
who was killed by the reverse-flash
he had Barry's dad who was killed by a
zoom you had Harrison wells who was kind
of a lie to all of them for their entire
life that he had Eddie Thawne who shot
himself to save the day the unit Ronnie
Raymond who died inside of a black hole
yet irises mom who had a cancer he had a
Laurel Lance was killed in a different
show you had Leonard snart who
sacrificed himself on a different
I people died and finally speaking of
Captain cold I love that Caitlyn is now
using his cold guns kind of like one
inside joke she's hiding her ice powers
he might come back at some point I mean
come on he's like a fan favorite we need
him back but anyways guys let me know
what you guys think what other
characters would you like to see on the
show hit me up in the comments down
below or on Twitter at Sam bash or make
sure you like this video subscribe to
the channel new rock stars because we
have a bunch of awesome videos coming
out for you and make sure you check out
all the other ones we have here made by
all the lovely people on this channel
again guys my name is Sam basher and
I'll see you next time